[Music]
hello and welcome back to this week's
Friday face off with me el the deputy
beauty editor at glamour UK and the
talented youtuber Lucy flight so we're
about to be shown a makeup look which
we're gonna have to recreate in five
minutes we've not seen it before so this
will be the first time what are you
thinking I feel like the eyebrows are
similar to I put my eyebrows now so I
feel like actually yeah I am eyebrows of
fun looks like like a superhero type
yeah like a bit of Wonder Woman yeah
it's very very bold yeah I'm a little
bit intimidated but how are you
confidence levels did you think I'm
gonna be able to do this one in five
minutes maybe one eye yeah like in five
minutes I'll be able to complete that
full thing but I guess we'll see
[Music]
well do you have four eyeliners yeah I
also have two very bright looking poets
yes I also have two very bright looking
palates I've got one from next it's the
off tropic palette and it looks super
exotic and I've also got a berry m1
which I didn't realize they actually did
massive palettes like this it kind of
looks like a custom one what are you
starting with I'm starting with the red
I'm doing the red as well wow this is
very bad
yeah this is very red look ill aren't
weird it's not neat no I do not do red
eyeshadow the thing is this girls
brunette I'm blonde it'll eat you know
what I mean I've been bleeding for my
eyes may I have absolutely nailed this
eyeliner have you that's actually rude
why don't the eyeliner
oh my god I'm rubbish at this I'm
actually talented I was saying I really
big myself up didn't I saying that but
I'm only gonna do one eye and then I'll
be trash after that side all the way
across the top it's just don't work is
it I look stupid I should I look like
I'm a blue cheese straight aren't The
Incredibles this looks like I've tried
to do drag makeup and it's just really
not went well drag makeup are so so good
and this just looks absolutely
ridiculous I don't understand how Joan
Smalls is pulling this off to be honest
oh come on
I've poked myself in the eye the thing
is because I've got such big eyes she's
got a lot of space and she kind of looks
like this in the picture yeah I can't
wait for you to see the liquid liner
that I've got going on on the top there
[Music]
I just can't be the line underneath it's
just not gonna happen is I'm gonna end
up poking myself all over my eyes I'm
gonna leave that out and try and find
out this right I'm gonna do a lip I'm
gonna do it
my god I've looked at myself like so far
back cuz I was just sort of focusing in
on the zone so you're sick service needs
do you know what mine looks like you
know like I mean I've turn off when we
give myself a 5 taking I feel good
you've got an 8 for sure at least really
yeah I'm top of that I'm gonna give
myself a turn forever thanks for
watching our Friday face off like and
subscribe to Grammy UK's YouTube channel
for more videos like this and let us
know what you thought in the comments
below
[Music]